this video is brought to you by
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community with more than 22
thousand courses right now the first 500
people to click the link in the
description can get two whole months of
Skillshare for free it is one of the
greatest nations in the world Germany is
the linchpin of the European Union an
economic powerhouse that's also home to
one of the world's top creative capitals
despite a history scarred by two world
wars and 45 years of partition under a
communist dictatorship it's a nation
that's consistently been at the center
of global affairs for a hundred and
fifty years and it only exists because
of one man when Otto von Bismarck was
born Germany was a collection of 39 weak
states cowering between the superpowers
of France Austria and Russia by the time
he died the German nation had been
forged in blood and iron and Central
Europe had a new sheriff in town but
while we all know the modern Germany he
gave us few of us know much about
Bismarck himself in this video we take a
look at the man known to history as the
iron Chancellor and just before we get
into the main part of the video today I
do want to say that there are a lot of
Xia German pronunciations if I screw
them up I apologize
[Music]
when Otto von Bismarck was born in the
Prussian village of Shon housen on April
the 1st 1815 it was into a world that
had been shattered by war not ten years
before Napoleon's Grand Army had come
storming through Central Europe
destroying the Holy Roman Empire ins
leaving
the Germanic states in ruins Bismarck's
own home of Prussia had been deeply
humiliated by a French military
occupation not the young otto was aware
of any of this less than three months
after he was born Napoleon was defeated
at Waterloo for baby also Napoleon's
defeat meant being able to grow up on
his parents estate without war that's
right estate
despite the image of later cultivate as
a man of the people Otto von Bismarck
came from the Prussian nobility his
father was a younger kind of minor
aristocrats while his mother came from a
family of middle-class professionals
still money does not equal comfort aged
7 Otto strict mother sent him away to
school in the Prussian capital of Berlin
and experienced that also absolutely
hated he hated it so much in fact that
the experience gave him a lifelong
loathing of strong women like his mother
while otto was cycling in Berlin Europe
was trying to rebuild itself after
Napoleon the destruction of the
thousand-year-old Holy Roman Empire had
left a void in the center of the
continent to fill its the surviving soup
of ours created something called the
German Confederation a collection of 39
states locked in loose association the
Confederation was designed to be weak
its power was balanced between the
Catholic Austrian Empire in the south
and the Protestant Kingdom of Prussia
where Otto von Bismarck was born in the
north now as we run through Bismarck's
life it's important to remember there
was nothing at this stage that even
remotely resembled modern Germany when
you hear us say Bismarck studied in
Hanover it wasn't like you moving from
say Colorado to Washington it was
literally like moving to another country
albeit one where they just happened to
speak the same language this language
thing was why people started wondering
why there were 39 Germanic states in
said of one United Germany well that's
something we're gonna get to in a moment
for now all you need to know is that
Otto ends at göttingen University in
Hanover in the 1830s and he studied to
be a lawyer remarkably verbs such a
great man he was use
as a student his friends considered him
a dandy is tutors considered him a drunk
he scraped through his course and joined
the Prussian civil service a terminally
boring occupation in fact it was so
boring that Bismarck wrote the Prussian
civil servant is like one musician in an
orchestra he's confined to his own
little part I however want to make my
own music it's a quote bismarck fans are
fond of because it points to his future
greatness at the time though their
future greatness it was very much in
doubt bismarck actually quit the civil
service in 1839 after his mother died
and he returned to his father's estate
there he briefly became a bible-thumping
evangelical before marrying the pious
Jana van put camera and living as just
another Russian farmer the one notable
thing he did came in 1847 when he was
sent to the Prussian Parliament and made
a number of speeches attacking the
nation's Jews in this stage in his early
30s he really was little more than a
random hick from Pomerania so you might
know the saying cometh the hour cometh
the man well no one in 1847 Europe
Newars but the hour was very nearly upon
them and the man he was already there
in the library of European history 1848
is simply the giant red volume titled
wool on February 20 seconds' a French
government ban against banquets led to a
Paris uprising which deposed the King
barely three weeks later on March the
12th a similar uprising in vienna
toppled clemens von Matunuck the guy
who'd been holding Europe together since
Napoleon's defeat it was a spread of
revolution a contagion of uprisings and
after Matunuck fell nowhere was safe
within days
Berlin was paralyzed by rats which
nearly brought down the conservative
Prussian King Friedrich Wilhelm the
fourth it was only by promising a slew
of liberal reforms that Friedrich
vilhelm was able to cling on to his
power one of those reforms well people
could now discuss the possibility of
uniting Germany for a guy who's famous
for uniting Germany you might be
surprised to hear Otto von Bismarck
wanted no part of this nationalist
revolution while liberals in Prussia and
other German states were holding
elections and creating a parliament to
write a new pan-german constitution
bismarck was considering arming his
peasants and marching on Berlin to
preserve Prussian sovereignty in the end
though bismarck settled for using his
position in the Prussian Parliament to
become one of the loudest anti
revolutionaries in Europe the thing
you've got to remember is that Germany
had never really been a thing before for
Bismarck uniting all 39 states in the
German Confederation meant turning his
beloved Protestant Prussia into a
support player in a nation dominated by
the Catholic Austrians on top of that
the guys now pushing to unite Germany
were all middle-class liberals while
Bismarck was a reactionary ultra
conservative aristocrat he loved his
King he loved God and he loved to order
for this mark 1848 must have been a bit
of a living hell but that turbulent year
it did provide bismarck with one
important boost it brought Bismarck
firmly to Friedrich Wilhelm the fourths
attention surround the revolution
Bismarck was one of the most Pro
monarchy men in Prussia even when it
seems the old order was about to be
swept away he clung stubbornly to the
past like a reactionary German limpet so
when the forces of counter-revolution
finally are control in 18-49 Bismarck
was
we placed to reap the rewards as the
revolutions failed in Prussia Austria
and elsewhere thousands of German
liberals were forced to flee to America
by 1851 the old order had been
completely restored fez services to the
Prussian crown Bismarck was made
ambassador to the city-state of
Frankfurt of all of the countries rocked
by 1848 only one underwent permanent
change in France where it all kicks off
the old monarchist order was destroyed
in its place a president rose up who
soon would become an emperor
his name was Napoleon the third and if
you've already seen our biographic video
on him
you all know he and Otto von Bismarck
were destined to collide with enough
force to reshape the continent
on September the 30th 1862 a giant of a
man
slowly lumbered to his feet in the
Prussian Parliament and he delivered a
speech that would change European
history at six foot four and with a body
built not unlike a particular type of
brick outhouse Otto von Bismarck was a
presence that always commanded attention
but on this day it was his words rather
than his size or volcanic temper that
set everyone talking in the 11 years
since 1851 Bismarck had been serving as
Friedrich Vilhelm ambassadors of the
capitals of Europe
he'd been in Frankfurt some Petersburg
had even briefly been stationed in the
court of Napoleon the third in Paris and
being so close to the levers of power
had given him time to think
slowly Bismarck had come to the
realization that the world was changing
whether he liked it or not
men's dreams of a united Germany they
hadn't died with 1848 and the Catholic
Austrians were ascendant in the German
Confederation even without a union
either the Prussian giant stood by and
watched the Liberals and the Austrians
dreams come true or he'd beat them at
their own game
it was from these musings that
Bismarck's famous blood and iron speech
sprang on that day September 30 of 1862
Bismarck was in a precarious position
roughly a year before Friedrich Vilhelm
the fourth had died and the Prussian
crown had passed to his dull and
dim-witted son Phil Hellmuth first
before 12 months passed Phil Hammett
accidentally sparked a crisis that
nearly toppled his government the short
version is that he needed tax rises that
the Liberal dominated Prussian
Parliament simply wasn't willing to pass
with it looking like another revolution
might be on the cards
Wilhelm panicked and recalled his
father's old acolyte Bismarck from Paris
to become Russia's minister president no
one expected Bismarck to last eight
weeks and now here he was now to deliver
his first major speech to a hostile
parliament nobody could have predicted
what a bombshell it would be in his
booming dramatic voice Bismarck declared
the position of Prussia in Germany will
not be determined by its liberalism but
by its power he went on to say not
through speeches and majority decisions
will the great questions of the day be
decided that was the great mistake of
1848 and 18-49 but by iron and blood for
the first time here we see Bismarck
addressing the Revolution of 1848 and
not as something horrific and to be
forgotten but as something that was just
done wrong Parliament have tried talking
and building a consensus and all it had
done was made chaos now it was time to
do it right it was time to unify Germany
with iron and blood to be clear iron
didn't just mean war it meant rapid
industrialization it meant a Prussia
that was building ships and bridges and
railways so fast that it could catch up
with Britain and France but yes it also
did mean war nobody in the Parliament
knew it but Bismarck was about to embark
on three great Wars that would take
Germany from 39 shattered States to a
single beer moth and a Prussian control
so the Liberals in Parliament their iron
and blood was the last thing they wanted
to hear they tried to force vilhelm the
first to remove his new minister
president from power even refusing to
work with him when this marketing and
collecting new taxes without their
approval
not that this bothered Bismarck did
return to Prussia with a plan to forge
Germany in his conservative and
Protestant image and the wheels forged
from the strongest iron were already in
motion okay so good news everybody we're
about to get into the war part of his
life which I know you will love war
apparently very popular on this channel
but first Skillshare and so are you
ready for a silky smooth transition
because maybe you noticed leadership
skills pretty important for all Bismarck
and leadership skills are something you
can learn on Skillshare how about that
presentation essentials career
development communication skills body
language all on Skillshare but it's not
just a leadership skill shet is an
online learning community with more than
22,000 courses every time I make one of
these as it sounds like they've added
like a thousand new courses it's
impressive
they have classes from design to
business technology and much more so you
know a lot of online learning platforms
they charge you buy the course which can
get pretty pricey after a while if you
like learning premium membership with
Skillshare though it lets you dive into
any course you want so you can learn all
of the leadership skills you want or you
know that other stuff I mentioned like
technology or I mean they've even got
culinary skills languages there's a lot
to learn for me I've learned about video
making on Skillshare useful for what I
do you can learn whatever you like
learning new skills is one of the most
important things you can do to get ahead
and
girl sure makes that super easy and
super affordable since culture is
sponsoring this video the first 500
people to click the link in the
description below can get two whole
months of Skillshare for free and let's
get on to that war shall we
the British prime minister Lord
Palmerston once remarked only three
people have ever really understood the
schleswig-holstein business the Prince
Consort who is dead a German professor
who has gone mad and I who have
forgotten all about it
all of this is just our way of saying
that you don't need to worry about the
super complicated backgrounds of the
second Schultz vig war all you need to
know is that Shullsburg and Holstein
were two regions on the border between
the German Confederation and Denmark and
that on February the 1st 1864
Bismarck convinced the Austrians to join
him in invading them the second big war
today is seen as the beginning of the
German Wars of unification more or less
everything went according to Bismarck's
plan Prussia and Austria stomped to
Denmark occupied the peninsula and
within months a taken control of shells
fake Holstein whole Stein went to
Austria
while shawls fig went to Prussia in the
21st century it's fashionable of
historians to debate where the Bismarck
really was a genius or just
extraordinarily lucky it's certainly
true that the second false pig war was
possible only thanks to a convenient
secession crisis in shawls fake Holstein
Bowl Austria had no beef with specific
Holstein they didn't even want to invade
but Bismarck managed to convince Vienna
that not joining his war would make
Prussia too powerful in the German
Confederation so join it Austria did a
move that cost them most of their allies
just as Bismarck wanted with Austria
diplomatically isolated Bismarck then
checked in on his old friend me Napoleon
the third to ask if Paris had any desire
to protect Vienna when de Polian the 3rd
was all like as cool did Bismarck said
about engineering his second major war
in January of 1866 Bismarck found a
pretext in Austria's administration of
Holstein
again the ins-and-outs they don't really
matter what matters is that by June
Austria and several German states
including Hannover were ready for war
with Prussia this this was an
exceptionally bad move
the moment the starting unfired on the
seven weeks war Prussia's ultra-modern
ultra efficient army was bulldozing its
way across Central Europe crushing
everything in its path seven weeks after
the conflict exploded with the Austrian
army being utterly defeated back in
Berlin Kaiser Wilhelm he couldn't
believe his luck he and his General
Staff could already envisage prescient
troops marching through Vienna but
never happens Bismark Bert is extremely
heavy foot down there would be no March
on Vienna no humiliating peace treaty of
Austria all he wanted to do was force
Vienna to promised that they'd never
join a united Germany and if they agreed
then any future Germany would naturally
be dominated not by the Catholic
Habsburgs but by the Protestant
Prussians this practically gave Vilhelm
a stroke the Kaiser was so adamant
Austria be crushed that Bismarck had to
threaten to throw himself from a fourth
floor window if Vilhelm gave the order
to march on Vienna in the end Bismarck's
theatrics they carried the day the
Austrians agreed to leave the whole
uniting Germany thing to Prussia and
Vienna was left standing back in Berlin
the two wars had made Bismarck a hero
even the Liberals who tried to get him
fired today
now sung his praises the chorus got even
louder when Bismarck annexed ice Vic and
Holstein and Hanover and forced every
Germanic state north of the river mine
into his North German Confederation by
the ends of 1867 those 39 Germanic
states we start at this video with had
been reduced to just five in the south
there were Bavaria bharden votin burg
and hesse-darmstadt in the north miss
marks new Prussian dominated North
German super state straddled the Baltic
Sea although was needed now was some
pretext forgetting the southern states
on board with this new thing called
Germany
luckily Bismarck he had plans for one
final war
[Music]
for most in Europe the creation of the
North German Confederation was greeted
with enthusiasm for liberals and German
nationalists there was the moments
they'd been waiting for since 1848 for
the major powers there was a use for
corrective to the void left by the Holy
Roman Empire's destruction but there was
one man who was very displeased with the
way things were going in Paris Napoleon
the third he stood in bitterness having
given Bismarck his blessing to go to war
with Austria the French Emperor had been
expecting something in return and made
moves to annex Luxembourg for France but
Bismarck stopped him worse he threatened
to go to war over Luxembourg's
neutrality suddenly France was looking
like the weak European power against
this booming new nation of Germany so
when a succession crisis blew up Spain
in 1870 and Prussia tried to step in
Napoleon the third decided to assert his
empire as you all know if you watched
our video on the polian the Third's and
trust us these two videos do really
complement each other rather well paris
dispatched the French ambassador to m's
where he accosted a vacation in Kaiser
Wilhelm the first the two had an
argument and that was that only it
wasn't quite see Bismarck somehow got a
hold of a memo about that argument by
now a master of the dark arts of
politics
see subtly edited what had been said so
it appeared that French honor had been
unforgivably insulted known as the Ames
dispatch Bismarck's edited memo did its
job perfectly
when bismarck leaked its contents to the
press the French public was so outraged
that Napoleon the third declared war for
the previous three years Bismarck had
been trying to control the southern
Germanic states into joining his new
Confederation but without any success
but with the French suddenly preparing
to invade Prussia through those southern
states the hold out German rulers they
changed their tune terrified of a dollar
store napoleon rampaging through their
backyards bavaria and the rest fled into
this marx embrace bismarck made it
simple his army would protect them from
the French on one condition they join
his new German Empire once he had his
agreements Bismarck set out to crush the
French the French guns are Warwick's
peck ting the other European powers to
join them that Austria was now on good
terms with Prussia Ravin that hold not
invading Vienna thing while the Italians
loved Prussia for giving Austria a
kickin Britain and Russia
meanwhile simply didn't care about a
squabble between Paris
Lenin so when the threadbare French army
finally attacked the well-trained
Prussian one on August the 4th 1870 it
wasn't even a rout it was a massacre
over the next month the Prussians
humiliated the French first they
scattered their army then they invaded
France then they laid siege to Paris
finally on September the 2nd 1870 the
Prussians surrounded and captured
Napoleon the third it was the death blow
for the second French Empire it was also
the birth of the German one On January
the 18th 1871 Bismarck and vilhelm
travelled to Louie the fourteenth old
Palace of Versailles to declare the
creation of the German Empire it was
touch-and-go at the last moment vilem
decided he didn't want to be Emperor but
rather to be king and it was only after
another multi hour screaming match that
Bismarck convinced vilhelm that if you
don't do this now dum-dum everything
we've been working for in the last
decade will be lost finally though the
Empire it was declared beneath a ceiling
fresco of louis xiv invading the holy
roman empire french representatives
surrendered the territory of
alsace-lorraine to germany and agreed to
pay an indemnity of five billion francs
not 20 kilometers away Russian bombs
continue to fall on the citizens of
Paris leaving them shell-shocked in more
ways than one
almost a quarter of a century after the
liberal revolutionaries of 1848 had
failed to do so with speeches Bismarck
had finally created Germany with blood
and with iron it was the dawning of a
brave new world and Europe but it would
never be the same again
if the 1860's were Bismarck's decade of
war the 1870s and 1880s whereas decades
of peace with France crippled in Germany
suddenly a thing the other powers sat at
the table all started exchanging uneasy
looks with one another wondering if this
new beer-swilling nation was going to
start something but they needn't of
worried unlike kaiser wilhelm ii or
Hitler or Napoleon Bismarck was a
conqueror who believed in restraint with
the franco-prussian war ever he halted
German expansion he turned his attention
to internal security while future
generations would assume Germany's
existence was a matter of destiny
Bismarck knew how fragile his new Empire
was instead of fighting now is the time
for ruling as dual Minister presidents
of Prussia and Chancellor of the new
Germany
Bismarck ruled with a strange
combination of enlightenment and
repression on the enlightened side he
introduced universal male suffrage
he established a national health care
system he introduced accident insurance
and brought in old-age pensions this was
Europe's very first modern welfare state
and it was complemented by enlightened
acts on the world stage in 1885 Bismarck
hosted a great power conference that
ended the Scramble for Africa he also
devoted himself to European peace going
out of his way to accommodate Russia
England Austria Italy even France but
behind this enlightened statesman lay a
guy who just couldn't stop himself from
occasionally acting like a petulant
dictator in the early 1870s for example
Bismarck launched a policy known as
kulturkampf dressed up as these things
usually are as a way of preserving a
native culture it was really just an
excuse to crack down on German Catholics
and try to turn them into good Prussian
star Protestants this was followed in
turn by a crackdown on socialists and
Social Democrats and basically anyone to
the left of Bismarck which was basically
everyone under 50 Bismarck was terrified
of exiting in his own revolution so he
assumed cracking down on the forces he
feared would keep him in office forever
but while Bismarck was never overthrown
he couldn't keep his enemies out of
government either when the election of
1890 rolled around two decades of
anti-catholic anti socialist policies
resulted in a landslide
for the anti Bismarck forces however it
was 1888 rather than 1890 that proved to
be
Mark's undoing in German history 1888 is
known as the year of the three emperors
that's because on March the ninth
Vilhelm the first passed away and
Frederick the third became Emperor this
market known for years that Phil Homme
was on the way out and it spent all that
time grooming Frederick just as had done
Frederick's father unfortunately for
this marks well laid plans
Friedrich the third at last engines 99
days in office before dying himself in
his wake another man rose to the
imperial throne a man who would go down
in history for all the wrong reasons
and that's Kaiser Wilhelm the second
film the second was everything Bismarck
couldn't stand he was impulsive sulky
prone to absurd decisions and most
importantly utterly unwilling to listen
to a stuffy old windbag who'd served his
grandfather and great-grandfather barely
had vilhelm the seconds backside warmed
the imperial throne then he publicly
dismissed Bismarck in 1890 the iron
Chancellor returned to his old estate in
a half expecting the governments to
recall him at any moments but they never
did although he lived eight more years
Bismarck would never be in a position of
power again
[Music]
if this marks life had been the great
roar of an iron ox his retirement was
the bellowing of a winded Bowl until his
death Bismarck wrote books and pamphlets
and made long speeches lionizing himself
while tarring vilhelm ii and his
government is a bunch of incompetent
boobs while this was doubtless cheering
to his supporters it blades an
unfortunate precedent Bismarck self
mythologizing rents cemented the image
of Bismarck the blacksmith who
single-handedly forged Germany's destiny
it was an idea that hung around in
German politics into the mid 20th
century influencing another
self-proclaimed mount of destiny Adolf
Hitler unfortunate too was the way
Bismarck simply Ran's it rather than
taught in his life had created a complex
system of alliances and friendships to
ensure no other power tried to attack
Germany but the system was so complex
that no one else could really grasp it
and so his departure it marked the
beginning of the slippery slope towards
World War one finally on July the 30th
1898 is marked passed away in his last
moments he expressed regret that he
hadn't been kind to his dog Sultan
before saying that it soon see his wife
Joyner again he was 83 from our
perspective it's impossible to overstate
how important Bismarck was he managed to
take a group of disparate European
states and transform them into a single
United whole it's telling that even in
the wake of World War one and World War
two no one ever seriously considered
breaking Germany up again even the
creation of communist East Germany ended
with the two Germany's reuniting in 1990
modern Germany may be smaller than it
was in Bismarck's day but its continued
existence is now a geopolitical given
can we imagine a world without Bismarck
certainly it would look very different
from our world today Berlin would be a
backwater the European Union likely
wouldn't exist and Germany would just be
a crazy dream some wayward liberals had
once back in 1848 on the other hand
would have no world war one no world
water you know Hitler no gurgles no
Final Solution
would it be a better world well this far
removed what we could say is that it'd
be unrecognizable those who followed
Bismarck may have used his creation for
evil ends but there's no doubt the iron
Chancellor himself was a great man of
history
Bismarck once said that he wanted to
make his own music on
world stage even now over a hundred and
twenty years after his death were still
wall singing from his hymn sheet so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and do not forget to
subscribe brand new videos just like
this several days a week also please
check out our fantastic sponsor skill
share the link below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]